[Music]
foreign
Tyson Fury Tyson Fury loses it in
interview with YouTuber true Geordie and
falmost runt to be Fearless enough
almost I thought he was all right I've
been called worse but I mostly you a lot
probably I thought I'd do a little
reaction because there's been so much
[__] said about it and to be honest with
you easy money I know you just double up
on the content some of us aren't afraid
to admit when they're getting a bit of
an easy payday just saying Tyson if
you're watching some of this video May
trigger you so just put the phone down
if if you if you know how all right
first thing as you can see here bold by
choice I want to get that out the way
because some of you a lot boldy Tyson
included pot kettle black by the way I
don't know if he was just sort of
jealous I took his luck from him and did
it better than him so jealousy there do
you think I think there might have been
just a little bit if you didn't want to
punch us before you're definitely going
to want to purchase at the end this
Tyson but on the plus side that might be
a fight you can actually sell I'm sorry
sorry genuinely at this stage there'd be
more people who'd want to see me against
Fury and by the way not interested the
chisora against Fury that is that's
ironic right so you've all seen the
video but just to quickly recap my main
two points are as follows Derek chazora
is a warrior there was never any dispute
of that from me even though Tyson tried
to make it out like I was trying to do
him down I get why he picked that
argument it's an easy position to take
in that moment ultimately I've I've
viewed Derek chazora as like the BMF of
boxing in MMA UFC we have the BMF uh
title which is like for the guy who will
have a war with anyone not a
um a man you want to meet and a dog Ali
you know a dangerous character who who
gives it is all every single time and
that is Derek chazora through and
through but unfortunately when you have
a lot of Wars you know you become worn
out and that is precisely what's
happened to Derek and I do think that
they need to manage him carefully and
one way to do that would be how about
don't put him in there with the most
dangerous heavyweight in the world right
now just a thought uh secondly that this
does feel like a bit of a pay a day jobs
for the boys scenario and one that the
Great British public should not be
charged pay-per-view prices for for a
fight that we know is not competitive in
the least
we've seen that because Tyson virtually
had to wave it off himself last time and
their pair of them were basically
getting booed for multiple rounds at the
end that wasn't a contest then and that
was when Derek had a lot more fight in
him than what he does right now a couple
of points that Tyson made in his
arguments with me uh one was he doesn't
care about Legacy I'd beg to differ
obviously I think the fact that he was
named after Mike Tyson shows that Legacy
has been drilled into him from day one
you know he's all about Legacy he talks
about being the greatest of all time a
lot he has studied the greats he often
references them and again he tripped
himself up multiple times by saying it's
not about Legacy but then the reason why
he's doing it is to make history well I
mean those two things are exactly the
same and it's all about him having two
trilogies at heavyweight which turns out
he thought he was the first many people
have corrected him that he wouldn't be
the first it's like me going am I better
than Joe Rogan and Ricky Gervais said
podcasting absolutely but I don't care
about Legacy all right but just to be
clear I am the goat Tyson then sort of
refutes that this isn't an easy pay a
day for his mate an easy money for him
that you know he's a fighting man and it
isn't about that for him but then why
have you on your third autobiography
when you've only had one life you know
why do all those speaking to us why are
you now advertising life insurance and
and I'm I may well need that it may be
ironic that Tyson Fury's life insurance
pays out after he kills me
um I've got no problem no problem with
Tyson making that money I love to say a
young man who's come from nothing make
that money but then just don't just tell
us that you're not about that when
you're clearly charging the public for a
non-competitive fight and you're having
the Bamboozle yourself to make sense of
it all and none of it makes sense that's
why there's been such an overwhelming uh
support for the video is because people
are just sick and tired of this and no
one's ever said it to him he then said
he wasn't in the same era as music and
Joyce but he was in the same era was AJ
when AJ Town pro at the same time as you
sick uh Joyce is older than him like
just mental gymnastics gone wrong again
then he was saying you know there was a
deadline for AJ but not for chisora
because chazora's got balls and all of
that and it's just the whole thing it
was very hard to go along with and I
personally and I know some of you might
disagree I don't think Fury actually
pulled out I think Fury became very
difficult to work with but I think after
actually AJ side may have been the ones
to just pull the plug but either way he
just makes dealing with him in a
business sense very difficult and as the
fans we want to make this fight happen
we want to say this fight happen and
it's [__] frustrating and like why
does it have to be December 3rd you're
calling the shots to make a fight that
no one wants to see and you're hiding
behind your self-imposed deadlines as
the reason those fights have to happen
and why we're not getting better
opponents when you made those deadlines
yourself and then you're going to charge
us a fortune for it so yeah none of it
sounded good did it so as the interview
was going on and I could feel him
getting more frustrated I I didn't let
that shake me you know because I thought
there's things that need to be said
right now and I'm going to be as
respectful as I can be and luckily a lot
of you out there recognize the amount of
respect I paid Tyson and still say what
needs to be said but ultimately this guy
does not respect me and he he thinks I'm
beneath him it's who who the hell are
you to tell me what I need to be doing
ego is an amazing thing when it comes to
becoming heavyweight champion of the
world you know you want to prove to
everyone that you're better than
everyone else and you go and do it and
then you get to say haha I told you so
it must feel [__] amazing right but
when it comes to then having that same
ego and having a chat with a fan who
merely questions your decisions it's
problematic because Tyson puts himself
across as a man of the people but as
you've seen in that interview you know
you can't be a man of the people and
then not be answerable to those same
people who pay your wages and buy all of
your products
and think that they don't deserve any
explanation at all but if you don't want
it don't buy it then that's just not the
attitude of someone who's a man of the
people and like he said who am I I am
not on Derek chazora's level I am not
Tyson Fury I'm nobody compared to him
and he clearly thought that then why is
it bothering you so much why are you
getting so triggered if what I'm saying
is a load of [__]
I think we all know and when he was
hurling all of those insults at me as
someone who I've genuinely looked up to
before but but but I know how he is at
times in terms of he can't redicts
himself a lot right we all everyone
who's watched a fury interviews seen
that he literally says good man and then
says you bulldozer within within seconds
and that's why I start laughing because
I'm like this is vintage Tyson like I've
never seen But even quicker to
contradict themselves like well I was a
good man the second ago what the [__]
just happened imagine I'd turn around
when he was in the middle of calling his
Baldwin just went I have got cancer so
sucks I don't have cancer just to be
clear I'm perfectly uh fine touchwood I
did thought I found a lump the other day
turned out uh I've just got massive
balls so yeah there was actually a few
people who thought I was deliberately
trying to wind him up just because I
wasn't backing down I'm like mate I
worked offshore 12 hour shifts every
[__] day all we did was piss each
other off right I've got a black belt in
pissing people off I'm from Newcastle
I've got my seventh [__] done in
pissing people off ask anyone who knows
me I can be the most annoying prick
you'll ever meet this was me being as
respectful as I could just to prove I've
even got Fury's books I think he's got
another one coming out here if you want
to buy it but um yeah now look at them
I've turned them into Ronnie Pickering
I don't want someone to get backlash off
an interview with me but equally I think
it was owned you know this is something
that's been in the post for him and
because he let that come out people were
like no we're not having this you have
to behave you're the world champion we
love you we look up to you we demand
better and we demand better than Derek
chazora and I was simply trying to hold
him to that standard of the greatest
fighter of this generation when putting
those questions to him because I want to
say the best out of him I don't want
however many fights he's got left one of
them to be wasted on a fight that's easy
we want to see him tested we want to see
him show the true giant of a man that he
is and the inside in his heart we want
to see that come out and I do think he
really needs to learn how to take a
normal bit of criticism what I did was
so normal how many people has he got
around him I were just sucking him off
to a degree where the least bit of
challenging and he loses his temper like
that like that is that is a prime
example of who you've got around you and
when you're the guy with all the money
everyone loves
it how how hard is it going to be for
him to walk away from all of that I I
think all of this chat about uh
retirement is a load of rubbish I think
he will be fighting as long as possible
because he loves the Limelight he loves
the money he loves and also the demons
that he has which are you know I share a
few of them myself to be fair and
um it's it's not it's not easy you've
got to find things to occupy you so I
think part of the reason he's actually
taking this chisora fight the one of the
reasons I actually excuse him for is I
just think he wants a [__] fight keep
him out of trouble and he is a boxing
genius it's just that sometimes with
people who I've interviewed who are
geniuses in a field they lose sight of
the fact of you're a genius at that one
thing but that doesn't give you the
right to treat everyone a certain way
just because they haven't achieved what
you have in that one field
and being a big man he's probably used
to people being scared and intimidating
I do want to thank the the boxing fans
who actually supported that video uh
heavily because I think a lot of them
had wanted to hear what I said to him
put to him for a long time and finally
someone did it was basically the overall
sentiment uh there was a couple of
people who had an attitude who were like
also in the boxing circles online I
think saying like who's this guy think
he is you know he's not he's not a good
interviewer he's not a boxer he's not a
boxing journalist who does he think he
is people said that I opened up the
questioning wrong which therefore pissed
Tyson Fury off and led to a bad
interview putting it on me it's quite
embarrassing when you can suggest that
me simply asking a question about KSI or
Conor Ben could then trigger Tyson Fury
to a point where he'd be that angry when
you can see from the minute go he ain't
in a good frame of mind anyone with an
ounce of of relations in their life to
other people will be able to [__] say
that but nevertheless let's take it out
for what it is no the KSI you shouldn't
be bringing him up well KSI has the
record on the Zone this year for higher
selling pay-per-view he is involved in a
major storyline right now with Jake Paul
and Tommy Fury Tommy Fury was a schedule
a fight Jake Paul who was at that press
conference on stage with Tommy Fury
Tyson Fury he is involved in this
whether you like it or not and Tyson
Fury has often commented on that whole
situation there is millions of clips of
him talking about Logan Jake KSI all of
that there's loads of the clips out
there so to say he's refused to talk
about it before is [__] he himself
is actually lined up fights before for
crossover boxing or whatever you want to
call it with Thor bionson and Francis
and ganu so to say that this is nothing
to do with him all right is he gonna
fake it I know but it just chastised me
for merely bringing the guy up what a
load of [__] get off his dick you
[__] sackless soft Pricks then
comment on the fact that I brought
Connor Ben up when it's the biggest news
story of the [__] year in boxing and
he himself has had his own issues with
ped uh discrepancies shall we say so
yeah he in in the same way class but to
say Connor Ben is none of Tyson Fury's
business like all right is he going to
fight him again no but would the people
be interested to hear his thoughts on it
absolutely what is my job to find that
out you [__] morons honestly all of
this is just a Justified Tyson's
Behavior ultimately part of those little
digs that I received were people who had
probably been showing up you know what I
mean who felt a bit you know this guy's
just jumped on the scene and boom put it
on him immediately how many hours have I
had with him well you know you know why
you know when you let's say I'm not
qualified if I've been interviewed Tyson
Fury well let me tell you some names
Ricky Gervais Louis Theroux Russell
Brand Jordan Peterson these are the
names I [__] with these are people who
come to my [__] house and have actual
sit-down interviews with me I ain't
running around chasing them while
they're doing other [__] these are
heavyweight intellectuals that I
interviewed so with all due respect
because I love Fighters and they're the
most entertaining people on the planet
to me but these guys don't get punched
in the head for a living these are very
smart people so for you to insinuate
when I interviewed that caliber that I
haven't got what it takes to interview
Tyson Fury you're a [__] [__] you
you really are like I don't know how
else to put it like you're a [__]
[__] these guys come from my audience
to access my audience that I've built
over years of interviewing fascinating
people all kinds of sports stars all
kinds of celebrities and that experience
that I've had has enabled me in five
minutes with Tyson Fury or whatever the
[__] it was to get more out of them than
a lot of these people criticizing me
have gotten in the last five to ten
[__] years so just you're
embarrassing yourself you're like
honestly I just just literally stop just
know you've picked the wrong one leave
it at that all right good but but
trijadi they know more about boxing than
you do well that may be true but you
know what you don't have to know [__]
about boxing and no chizora and fury
should not be fighting again telling me
I'm on a wind-up just because I didn't
take his first answer that's just
journalism how am I having to explain
this to [__] people who do this for a
living some of these people criticizing
me that is journalism taking someone's
first answer okay then that's what you
do when a you're a coward or B you're
getting paid by the guy who's doing the
interview oh you're scared to [__]
not get another interview again and
actually I have a level of empathy for
that but don't [__] come at me just
because I've got the balls to do it and
I've worked hard to get in a position
where it doesn't [__] matter if I
never speak the Tyson Fury again in a
day of my life that's why I laughed
because I couldn't give a [__] and I
know it's not fair and I know they
probably are a bit miffed that oh you
got the [__] viral clip and we've
been hanging around and for God knows
how long but you got too close
journalists you're too poly with them
and you need to keep that distance
between them so that you can ask those
questions and that's the problem in a
lot of these circumstances and also
Tyson's reaction shows why why they
don't because they will be banned and it
isn't fair
but don't blame me I am in love with
this sport you know and that's why I
could talk confidently with Tyson Fury
um despite never achieving anything in
it and look how many others have
achieved anything out of it it doesn't
mean that we're not entitled to a
[__] opinion especially as paying
customers so in terms of my relationship
with you a lot I'm always going to try
and give you the best interviews I can
and there won't be it won't be perfect
all the time and people will now be
looking at me to try and shoot me down
because I've stuck up for myself yeah
but that is the journey for integrity
you will make mistakes I will not get it
right every time but I'm Gonna Keep
[__] trying and I hope you appreciate
that because I do appreciate the level
of support you've given me don't forget
to hit that like button and subscribe
thanks to all of you a lot and I will
see you on the next one cheers